this is a trick question isn't it saved
by the siren talk to you later go
[Music]
love seeing you two together again
you always were my favorites
[Music]
we did the impossible doc but now I have
to destroy it with a little creation of
my own
[Music]
and once again we have live footage of
Mara Warren being held captive power
you want me to beg not gonna happen
the world will know the truth before
they mop you off the pavement tell them
what you did
I never everything you have is built on
lies
you stole my company my ideas now the
truth the truth okay
the truth is you were only ever worth a
damn when you work for me the truth is
you could never accept that I'm better
than you you're a failure Otto and you
always will be
[Music]
such a disappointment
Parker you know I tried to warn you
Peter but you didn't listen
yeah I won't let you win this means too
much to me
not more than it means to me
you look tired okay not tired
if you want to change the world you have
to be the kind of man
who can make the hardest decisions
I couldn't agree more
[Music]
Peter I saw you as a son I should have
known you turned on me just like all the
others sir I've worshipped you your mind
your conscience wanting to help others
the way you never gave up that's because
men do like us have a duty a
responsibility to use our talents in the
service of others even if they don't
appreciate it we have to do what's best
for those beneath us whether they
understand it or not no you're wrong
you are everything I wanted to be
you just threw it away
yes of course you're right Peter
oh I see that they're the neural
interface thank you my mind but I can
fix it
we can fix it together if you'll help me
do everything I can
I'll make sure you get the best out know
if they put me away they'll take my arm
I'll be trapped in this useless body
[Music]
please Peter
so ash wasn't me you said you'd never
abandoned me you promised remember
and of course your rest easy knowing
your secret is safe with me you do what
you think is best doc it's all honey of
his camp
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to play spider-man
ps4 and spot some of the really big
Easter eggs we're still doing the
giveaway four copies of the game all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a spider-man related comment
on the video uh name a new winner at the
end of this the Stan Lee cameo is funny
because they used to go there to that
diner when they were a couple the way
Stan Lee talks about it he was there
watching then the whole time within the
context of the game but it's also a
reference to Mary Jane and Peter Parker
being his favorite couple in real life
because the spider-man character has
been such a big comic book character for
him in his own personal history most of
you probably noticed though that that
last Doc Ock boss fight you'd get to
that pretty quickly and you unlocked the
anti octopus suit just through normal
gameplay there's no real special
requirements like you make it to the
final boss fight you automatically
unlock it but it does look really badass
even though he tried to make good with
Peter at the end Peters like he's too
far gone like even though I cared about
you a lot you are clearly insane now so
I think the idea is is that there'll be
some prison break in one of the sequel
games they haven't said anything
official other than the developers and
people associated with this Omni AK have
said that this is part of a big trilogy
so I think the idea is is that they'll
definitely be a sequel and then they'll
probably be a third game but remember it
takes years and years to make these so
we might not hear anything official
about that for quite a while till like
after they're well and done with all the
DLC packs for this version of the game
so obviously big candidates for villains
in the second game is gonna be venom and
Green Goblin because of that other post
credits scene I've already done a video
about that I'll link those at the end of
this congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video extra for
the win please email me on the about
page of my youtube channel so I can get
your details click here for the green
goblin venom post credits scene and
click here for that Captain Marvel
trailer announcement thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]